[music] [music] well, yes, this is your strength just at our village from not looking around, but in general, the axes are being surveyed service this mountain I don’t remember what it’s called the Crimean Tatars have exactly every top every tidy what’s there it can be seen by 82 names, and as I don’t remember, but this most famous one looks from the house that belonged to our ancestral home in the service from where they dispossessed sent the Urals of my parents, they safely fled from there but did not immediately return to Crimea, they arrived at Melitopol and then moved after all, they didn’t return to the Crimea, but they didn’t return to their native village because they could report or the KVD they settled ska riders in the area, this is the northern Crimea of ​​all men, I was born there in the forty-fourth year, they deported us from the Crimea, so I fought through this, in my opinion, that to treat which was later destroyed by the forces of our compatriots, their capabilities were established to the world and we are from here from Kyiv what kind of fish are with this help
and the decision of
this mosque when I was here and it was
somewhere in 2010, in my opinion, there
would be no development of an ugly state of its
floor
, but now something has been restored and the
dullness I sat only in 1989,
this will be my return to the Crimea, but  then
every year, like in all the villages of the Crimea, the
Kama Tatars built
the day of their native village on the same day in the year;
going through the house so
unprepossessing, but in those days, during the
dispossession of kulakization, the visibility of this creature
is very large
inside and a half, it’s there by Soviet standards, well,
it’s a great luxury, we
unfold it immediately, of course, the
question became whether to buy a house, at least the
memory of their parents
planned there  restore
repair make some kind of
recreation center for our compatriots you did not
succeed occupation  2000 14, the
Crimean Fund and all its property was arrested
and now it will give you it doesn’t appear and
then the Mejlis of the
Crimean Tatar people was banned because now
this house is in such a limbo
older people walked along this gorge
so the data told where who
lived what happened to them who was
shot who was deported and where
he died what are these members called these
mountains like this
[music]
elevators